hallo herzlich willkommen sallys wels
heute ist es endlich soweit
mein buch ist online mein zweites buch
sallys classics klassische und moderne
kuchen und torten also bevor ich jetzt
lange um den heißen brei herumreden
mein buch ist online aber bevor ihr
jetzt in den online shop geht um sich
anzuschauen
hört euch am besten arrangiert zu
erzählen habe denn ich werde euch
erzählen wie das buch entstanden ist was
die idee dahinter war und ein paar infos
natürlich darüber also mein erstes buch
kennen wahrscheinlich alle das sc lyss
rezepte für kinder das habe ich letztes
jahr gemacht und fast genau um die
gleiche zeit veröffentlicht zwar auch im
oktober/november fehler und dieses buch
hat viele rezepte vom frühstück über das
mittagessen gesunde snacks und salate
desserts bis hin zu kleinen backofen
gerichten also auch süße rezepte aus dem
ofen
das war eine kluge kinder genau das war
nicht nur für kinder aber es war eben
sehr einfach geschrieben dass es eben
auch kinder nach machen können oder auch
zum beispiel mirror oder männer oder
frauen die eben nicht so geübt sind und
im prinzip hat man in diesem buch ganz
viele rezept ich glaub sind über 80 aus
ganz vielen verschiedenen kategorien
wirklich für jeden was dabei
und in meinem zweiten und in meinem
zweiten wurf sallys classics habe ich es
nur musiker ja so ein großer unterschied
das war ein bisschen handlicher und das
ist jetzt ein bisschen größer denn ich
wollte dass wenn ich kuchen und torten
mache das man die natürlich auch schön
abbilden kann und dass die fotos richtig
toll darin aussehen vor allem habe ich
hier viele rezepte viel fachwissen mit
drin viel hintergrundwissen und ich kann
ja mal so ein bisschen was über den
inhalt sagen ganz kurz kannst du ein
buch rücken zeigen
im buch nicht verwechseln im telefonbuch
das ist wirklich fertig das buch umfasst
390 seiten und eigentlich hätten sogar
noch mehr werden sondern weil ich wollte
irgendwie von jeder torte sechs bilder
rein machen wir einfach alle ganz toll
aussehen aber wir haben uns für jeweils
zwei fotos immer entschieden
ja aber um was geht es im buch ich habe
verschiedene kategorien bei den torten
und kuchen ich habe einmal die
klassischen torten moderne torten
dann habe ich die kühlschrank torten
alsono baic ohne backen und ich habe die
kate major starts und kadlec
das heißt auch einer meiner lieblings
kategorien und habe ganz vorne mit drin
das einmaleins des backens und zwar geht
es dann darum dass ihr ein paar infos
bekommt über gewisse zutaten zum
beispiel über bug werkzeug und da stelle
ich einfach so ein bisschen vor was ich
immer verwendende was für zutaten nicht
verwende
und das einfach beim backen das
wichtigste auch weg durch die zutaten
sind und nicht das werkzeug das ist
immer ganz wichtig weil wir das fasten
fahrten ja eigentlich eigentlich ist
einfach ein bisschen haus
wirtschaftswissen mit drin und habe euch
meine youtube geschichte auch rein
geschrieben denn wir haben gemerkt immer
wenn wir auf messen sind dann fragen
mich meine zuschauer immer sandy wie
kannst du überhaupt dazu wie kamst du
zum backen zu kochen wie kannst du auf
die idee den youtube kanal so könnten
also habe ich mir gedacht in dieses buch
muss mit rein wie und wann habe ich mit
youtube angefangen und warum
ja das habe ich so ein bisschen erklärt
und was habe ich noch mit drin natürlich
den lostopf weil mit dem alles begann
gibt es auch natürlich das rezept und
sagt ich weiß auch ein paar fragen wo
leute stellen wird seine rezepte drin
aus seinen videos das ist alles ja genau
also zu 90 prozent sind das ganz neue
rezepte natürlich habe ich ein paar
klassiker trendy einfach drin sein
müssen sowie die schwarzwälder
kirschtorte der bienenstich der
legendäre mississippi die donauwelle
aber klar bei den klassischen torten
muss ich auch aus wiederholen denn
klasse schreiben sie der klassisch aber
viele rezepte sind auch ein bisschen
optimiert worden
und hier mit drin aber ansonsten sind
eigentlich die meisten also wirklich zu
90 prozent neue rezepte
das buch liegt fast doppelt so viel wie
das andere
dann erst wird also das kleine sage
jetzt das erste buch wiegt 1,1 kilo und
dass ihr weg 21 25 22 kilo und das ist
schon also
ja schon groß ja was habe ich noch mit
drin
am ende des buches habe ich natürlich
eine umrechnung tabelle mit drin die
findet etwa auch auf meinem blog auf
salehs - blog.de aber auch hier noch mal
mit drin das heißt alle torten die da
drin sind könnt ihr auch umrechnen um
sie größer oder kleiner zu packen und es
gibt sogar ein lesezeichen das hormon
sich da dem das vergessen wir zu
schicken
aber es gibt sogar ein lesezeichen genau
das eine umrechnung stabile genau und
reha muss einblenden
ja und hinten sind auch noch ist auch
noch dieses ort tabelle obst mit drin
dass sie einfach wisst welche frucht
welches obst hat gerade saison und ist
natürlich ein paar private bilder drehen
auch von samira el a von moralischem
wind mit drin ja ich habe und du hast
natürlich wieder die letzten genau das
einspruchsrecht sie kommt zum schluss da
habe ich wirklich wie vielseitig 10 122
33 seiten den drei seiten musste ich ein
klagen bei unserer rechtsanwalt ja da
hat die lektorin diesmal wieder
weggelassen weil es war einfach zu teuer
gewesen murats rechtschreibfehler
auszumachen ist
nein ja jeden fall sind wirklich tolle
rezepte mit drin und ich muss auch sagen
jede einzelne torte hat uns sehr gut
geschmeckt deswegen hat es natürlich
auch ins boot mit rein geschafft und
vielleicht noch ganz kurz zum
entstehungsprozess ein buch zu machen
ist natürlich sehr viel arbeit ich stand
hier wirklich in der küche und habe viel
gebacken und der markt ist unser
fotograf der hat die ganzen fotos
gemacht und ich habe manchmal bis zu
zwölf toten an einem tag gebacken und
die mussten dann parallel hergestellt
werden und fotografiert werden
ich habe hier auch step by step indoor
mit drin deswegen war es immer ein
bisschen schwierig zu koordinieren zu
planen und für mich ich musste immer
wissen was kommt wann und der mars
musste praktisch immer griffbereit
dastehen und dann die fotos schnell
schließen dann wieder das nächste set
aufbauen
dann will man natürlich verschiedene
untergründe ich habe ganz viele torten
platten besorgen müssen
die sieht man jetzt auch mittlerweile
hinten bei mir in der küche weil einfach
ja soll der schön werden und
das buch variationsreich die rezepte
wurden komplett bei unserer küche
gemacht ja alle ja da müsst ihr euch
vorstellen in meiner küche saß ab und so
aus also ich bin da nicht alleine
gewesen in der küche morath war da der
hat dann ab und zu mal raus gebracht das
hört sich kinder waren wirklich ein
gemeinschaftsprojekt ein familienprojekt
da man sich damals mit dabei tom und
frankfurt ab und zu mit dabei die
kameramänner andrea war ab und zu mit
dabei und da waren wir echt mal auch zu
sechst in der küche ich nebenher der
ganzen torten und kuchen gebacken markus
das set aufgebaut und es hat mich sehr
viel spaß gemacht aber ich war
irgendwann auch froh als die 60 torten
und kuchen fertig waren
das ist alles lange prozess das ist sehr
lange wochen genau vor allem bei der
kühlschrank natürlich immer vor wie
torten und ich habe am ende des tages
dann alle kuchen boxen zusammengesucht
die ich finden konnte und habe es dann
also die frage kommt bestimmt wer hat
die ganzen kuchen und torten gegessen
werden alles verteilt nachbarschaft dann
haben wir beim globus viel abgegeben so
aber meine eltern zur arbeit also
wirklich jeder hat kuchen und torten
probieren dürfen
und eigentlich war das feedback auch
immer sehr gut wir haben was ich ganz
schön fand es war jetzt nicht irgendwie
so dass zehn leute gesagt haben krass
diese torte war meine lieblingsorte
sondern es war immer verschieden
also ich denke dass ich wirklich so den
geschmack von vielen leuten treffen kann
mit den verschiedenen torten und jeder
findet etwas anderes richtig schön ja
was sollte man dann noch erzählen
ich hab dann natürlich alles nicht so
vorstellen ich habe erst die rezepte
entwickelt dann habe ich sie produziert
wir haben die fotos gemacht und dann
habe ich mich hingesetzt als alle fotos
gemacht waren und habe wirklich tagelang
wochenlang nur texte geschrieben
das heißt ich habe da jetzt keine
agentur oder eine autorin oder ghost
writer das für mich macht sondern ich
sitze dann da und schreibt die rezepte
natürlich muss ich dann immer so meinen
eigenen schreibstil entwickeln und ich
schreibe immer gerne in der du form
deswegen sind immer so persönlich und ja
dann alle texte schreiben dann ging's
zur lektorin zum korrekturlesen die
jesse hat dann die grafiken gemacht und
das buch ebenso gesetzt
dann hab ich noch mal zur kontrolle
gekriegt und am ende habe ich ungefähr
zehnmal
insgesamt kann man schon sagen
kontrolliert natürlich übersieht man mal
das eine oder andere aber so im ganzen
denke ich ist und schon richtig gut
gelungen oder ja jetzt doch die nächste
frage was war denn noch wichtiger was
waren wir noch richtig außer dass jetzt
meine lieblingsorte auf dem cover ist
war mir natürlich wichtig dass das buch
wirklich zu 100 regional hergestellt
wird das heißt wir haben das papier
genommen was in deutschland hergestellt
wird in reutlingen
wir haben eine druckerei gewählt die ja
gut 2000 quadratmeter hat ein kurzer weg
von der papier druckerei in der
papierherstellung in die druckerei weil
druckereien und saß bei der druckerei in
reutlingen haben wir das buch machen
lassen da war ich dann auch vor ort und
habe mir das angeschaut und ihr könnt
euch das nicht vorstellen diese
dimensionen an papier und an kopierten
und gedruckt nämlich kopiert zwar falsch
ich bin kein fachmann ausdruck sendet
mir leid aber da waren berge voller
papier und gedruckten seiten das war
echte haben sich den ganzen
herstellungsprozess wie es funktioniert
da war der druck hatte karl-heinz kann
schon mal dazu sagen du bist eigentlich
gelernter offsetdrucker bogenoffset das
heißt ich kann mir die ganzen maschinen
hieß es zum ersten mal diesen ersten mal
gesehen und dann kannst du die leute
kennen die dann an diesem buch dann auch
arbeiten und das war jetzt ich weiß
nicht ob das zu jedem sagen aber derart
exakt das war das schönste das ich
jemals gedruckt hat ja und das hat dann
nicht einfach sagt ernst hat die leute
kennen die deswegen drucken
du lernst die leute kennen das papier
herstellen es ist anders ist was sehr
faszinieren genau es ist alles wieder
regional er unter klar kann man so ein
buch dann auch im ausland herstellen
also in fernost bayerischen auflage da
ist es vielleicht kosten und bruchteil
aber ich finde einfach wichtig dass man
den ganzen prozess mit begleitet
einspringt er empfinde ist richtig weil
ich mein willigen ja auch wert darauf
dass
jeder möchte fair bezahlt werden jeder
möchte einen sicheren arbeitsplatz
deswegen muss natürlich auch jeder
darauf achten dass man eben auch
arbeitsplätze sichert und eben die
wirtschaft vor ort ankurbelt will und
nicht einfach ins günstigere ausland
geht was ich richtig toll fand ich meine
wenn ich eher zu hause was ausdrucke
dann habe ich halt einen drucker und der
druck auf einmal aus und ich dachte
druckerei ist genauso aber deutsche
diese verschiedenen böden und dann diese
fahren die aufeinander gedruckt werden
durch diese platten heißt es
druckplatten gruppe druckplatten oder
hat die druckplatte gelb und dann siehst
du alles was gelb ist ein dunkler oder
alles was schwarze und es war echt
faszinierend und wird schicht für
schicht gelb blau rot also magenta und
schwarz aufgedruckt ich finds kraft
gesehen da hat war die kumpel der
prozess auch in unserer hand ja ja ja
und ich muss sagen also die sabine aus
unserem shop
aber an unserem sehr sehr sehr sehr gute
freunde von uns und die sabine hat
geweint als er das buch in der hand
hatte
es ist doch schön auf der messe hat es
schon gegeben nachher vor ja das war
auch also ich hab das buch zum ersten
mal auf der messe in hannover in der
hand gehabt und ich war auch sehr
gerührt muss ich sagen war es nicht
verstanden oder und haben uns dann das
buch angeguckt murat und das war sehr
schön und auf der messe haben wir es
dann zum ersten mal auch hier haben die
zuschauer zum ersten mal gesehen
und wie gesagt gibt es jetzt bei uns im
online shop genommen
wo gibt es das buch soll wo gibt es das
buch das gibt es bei uns im online shop
jetzt und ab dem ersten dezember auch in
allen globus märkten
das heißt es in 847 märkte in ganz
deutschland immer mal wieder verteilt
wir bieten das buch nicht auf er müsse
noch einmal genau wie die fr
das war auch am alten buch so also alte
ständig dass ich auch erst ein jahr alt
war beim ersten buch so nur hat mir da
ein kleines problem und zwar wollte ich
eigentlich die kleinen büchereien vor
ort unterstützen und habe auch das buch
nicht an große büchereien gegeben also
nicht an dieser riesenkonzern das sage
ich ihnen mal und habe gesagt okay
kleine büchereien meldet euch bei mir
bekommt das buch ich möchte euch
unterstützen damit die leute die eben
nicht jetzt nicht online das kaufen
wollen vor ort das buch holen können das
ist mein offen ausmachen ich hab keine
torte drin was vielleicht raushole diese
ganzen zeit ist kein problem
ich backe übrigens gerade den lemon
mariachi skater den zitronen käsekuchen
aus dem buch vom cover wir haben das
buch angeboten für für kleinere buch
länger weil sie eine innenstadt
unterstützen wollten
das war einfach nur es gab manche kleine
buchläden was manchen er freilich sehr
viele buchläden die haare müssen rein
gehalt und wir kostet natürlich nicht
kontrollieren du kannst auch nicht
verbergen
und wir haben was tolles gedacht wir
unterstützen diese läden und und haben
selber nicht bei uns angeboten und ein
buch gemacht ja immer sehr schade weil
im prinzip hat das hat gegen alles
widersprochen was wir uns eigentlich
vorgestellt haben deswegen sei es wenn
sich wahrscheinlich wieder ganz viele
melden aber wir werden dieses mal es
leider nicht tun außer unsere buchläden
die wir hier vor ort haben das heißt
hier in kirrlach zum beispiel haben wir
buchen papier die wenn es natürlich
bekommen und weil das einfach nicht
kontrollieren kann und ich möchte nicht
dass mein buch auf amazon eben erscheint
ja ansonsten wie gesagt beim globus
markt oder bei uns online und auf messen
muss völlig über genau wie es sind gibt
es natürlich auch
ja ich denke dass euch das buch sehr
gefallen wir tragen dieser fokus
tschuldigung das buch kostet 34 90
und ich denke dass ich auch ein sehr
fairer preis also dass sie strömen ja
ich finde es ist nicht wenig ist aber
nicht viel
man muss dazu sagen sind 390 seiten und
es ist zu 100 prozent und deutschland
hergestellt und es ist sehr viel
fachwissen mit und zifferblättern genau
ist noch an also das finde ich auch
richtig gut ich habe auch gelernt aus
dem ersten buch wenn man das buch
aufschlägt und ich
ich muss natürlich viele bücher
signieren oder darf sie signieren
dann habe ich hier ein kleines feld wo
ihr ein foto mit mir zusammen oder ein
foto von eurer lieblings torte einkleben
könnt hier habe ich meine seite die ich
euch signieren kann
und ansonsten fängt dann eben an mit dem
inhaltsverzeichnis als ich hier seht ihr
auch die ganzen kategorien natürlich
schwarzwälder kirschtorte red velvet
cake bienenstich erdbeertorte donauwelle
hier drinnen ist übrigens die leckerste
etwa torte die ich je gemacht habe oder
auch pablo war ist presse torte kokos
torte after etr und so weiter falls
jetzt fragt was für verschiedene torten
da drin sind
ein apple pie blueberry mississippi
haselnuss tat wirklich 64 dann die
youtube geschichte und ja ganz viele
step by step bilder natürlich auch sowas
auch noch viel gefragt haben mir gesagt
34 90 war
dazu kommt noch vier euro 90 versand und
warum
na ja genau wir machen nämlich keinen
buchversand sondern nur den versicherten
versand
damit verfolgen können wo das buch
gerade ist und vor allem dass das buch
ist so groß und so dick das passt in
keinen briefkasten nicht stimmt das
heißt wir möchten nicht kontrollieren wo
das buch gerade ist er seine
lieblingsstrecke
ja absolut gratis presse die teams auch
die mache ich jetzt heute auch gerade ja
ich denke wir haben jetzt alles zum buch
gesagt und wenn ihr nach wie
versandkosten sparen möchte ab erster
dezember heißen in all goes 4
genau das ist es auch sagen eigentlich
nix uns auf jeden fall noch bei euch
bedanken
ja ich habe wonach genau bei der simone
immer noch ganz kurz zur simone
barcelona hat uns schon beim ersten buch
unterstützt mit ihrem klitzekleinen
einwand verlag mit dem echt lecker
verlag genau da muss auch die serie
heraus gesucht denn es gab sie sehr viel
verlagshäuser die jetzt um das buch mit
uns machen wollten
wir haben gesagt wir bleiben bei unserer
momentanen simone das ist ganz ganz voll
frau und danke simulations- geholfen
jetzt sie schreibt eigentlich
kinderbücher da könnte auch mal bei uns
schauen sehr richtig tolle kinder
geschichten und sie hat es diesmal auch
wieder ein bisschen geholfen einfach
kassette erfahren und wir eben noch
nicht so ganz
ja also ich hoffe dass ich das buch
gefällt lasst mir gerne ein feedback da
und ja ich bin echt gespannt drauf und
pakistan cheesecake weiter genau jetzt
müssen noch ein verstehen jetzt auf den
shop gehen kann es sein dass er zusammen
gerne bei witzen 19 ein neues system
haben und das ist optimiert und
verbessert aber meine seit gestern oder
seit vorgestern ist der neue shop online
das heißt ihr müsst euch komplett neu
einloggen
er hat jetzt eine ganz andere funktion
der mehr funktionen der
zahlungsmöglichkeiten
das ist ganz wichtig aber ihr müsst ihr
die alten passwörter funktioniert nicht
mehr
und das war's eigentlich das was ich
genau ab und vergiss nicht ambo am
dienstag ist feiertag das heißt es die
lieferung kann sich normalerweise hatte
li fung zwischen ein bis drei tagen
maximum
aber jetzt wird der feiertag drin ist
bei uns in baden württemberg bis freitag
bayern rheinland-pfalz kann es sein das
ist ein fakt der murat dugan
eurovision.de feiertag und so weiter in
ganz deutschland erklären aber ich würde
man sagen ich gehe weiter weil ich muss
noch einen kuchen fertig backen
ja was ich noch sagen wollte ich habe
hat jemand caro hin
viel spaß mit dem buch und stellt das
eingeschaltet habe bis zum nächsten mal
morgen gibt es nicht eine torte
morgen gibt es nicht ich mache meinen
job bisher